poupon a touché le poupon à la barre de
fleury michon le navigateur philippe
poupon en effet remporté à l'arraché et
à brest la victoire dans la course à la
voile en solitaire du figaro une
troisième victoire tout à fait
historique n'ayons pas peur des mots
reportage claude raynaud 2000 bonnet en
pénétrant ce midi en rade de brest
philippe vicariot nourrissaient encore
un vague espoir de victoire mais il lui
a suffit de tourner la tête et
d'apercevoir philippe poupon dans son
sillage pour comprendre que la course
était jouée depuis trois jours les deux
hommes ne s'étaient d'ailleurs jamais
vraiment perdu de vue avec seulement dix
petites minutes d'avancé au classement
général sur son rival philippe poupon
savaient qu'ils ne devait pas le laisser
filer dans cette dernière étape
philippe vicariot a bien été le premier
des deux a coupé la ligne aujourd'hui
mais cela n'a pas suffi arrivés deux
minutes plus tard c'est le capitaine
poupon qui a décroché le pompon
le professionnel l'a logiquement emporté
sur l'amateur commence à me faire
vraiment à l'idée que quelques temps que
je trouvais garou matin quand j'ai vu à
quoi j'ai vu sortir de la brume je suis
tapé la tête contre olten jouer
philippe poupon lui était plutôt fou de
joie à l'arrivée puisque il signe sa
troisième victoire dans la solitaire du
figaro
un exploit qu'il n'a pas empêché de
rendre hommage à son dauphin pas
beaucoup et me rencontrer sur leur dos
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui il a prouvé
qu'il pouvait gagner a vraiment la
victoire et elle était pour nous deux
points un avis pas vraiment partagé par
le public qui n'avait dit aujourd'hui
que pour philippe poupon le retour du
héros a été célébré en grande pompe